Obama has some concerns about media
coverage in America the former president
calling out what he sees as a double
standard for the non-stop attention the
doomed Titanic sub got versus the
migrant boat that sank off the coast of
Greece
obscene inequality 24-hour coverage
and I understand it of this submarine at
the same time right here in at just off
the coast of Greece we had 700
people that it's not dominating in the
same way and and in some ways it's
indicative of the degree to which
people's life chances have have grown so
disparate my eyebrows are so black
correct
um what do you think of the point that
Obama was making well this is like an oh
it's like an old Professor Phil morality
question like why do you care less about
the death of a large group of people far
away than someone you love so it's like
it's a false comparison in this case you
have one story of huge scale tragedy in
Greece and you have another that is more
intriguing
because it's an under it's a sub that
goes underwater which they do uh and
risks people's lives it's adventurous so
that makes it a more interesting
newsworthy story than the larger tragic
one a better comparison I think would be
people who live safe lives but die at
the hands of people who take risks
that's what I mean at least the people
that died in the ocean didn't take
anybody with them the people that
bothered me the most are the people that
he should be talking about criminals you
know people that that that kill innocent
people you know he's been very quiet
about some pretty big issues and and
Professor Obama could really come out
and make some like very you know strong
statements about the way the world's
gone he should be going on there and
going look at these people coming out of
the stores with 900 bucks worth of crap
that didn't happen when I was president
what the hell is going on that's what I
would like to hear instead of this kind
of like um well if they only cared more
about far away tragedies it's like okay
dude
dude what do you think
well when you're the citizen of the
world you always think about the world
instead of the United States remember
this is a guy whose father has roots in
Africa this is a guy who spent a lot of
his childhood in Southeast Asia is that
right I think it's right and then we ate
a dog Jesse I didn't bring that up but
I'm glad you did
and then spend a lot of time in Hawaii
was that the last state to get a star on
the flag not so sure about that but
he's never really looking at things from
an American perspective he's always
speaking to the world even when he's
speaking to us he's appealing to the
world so let me just tell you this is
not the BBC uh CNN Fox covered the story
the same way and here's why from a raw
news editorial standpoint
the Greek migrants that drowned there
was no Titanic angle number one huge
angle number two we had guests that knew
people that were submerged number three
there was suspense because we had the
countdown to the air shutting down and
uh this was off our Coast this is not
Greece this is the United States of
America if there had been a Cuban boat
that had capsized and there was Cubans
that were drowning off the coast of
Miami that would have been wall to wall
coverage we don't live in Europe Barack
Obama this is the United States of
America and it just shows how naive
detached and how snobby he is to not
understand that this is the United
States and as sad as it is and it was a
horrible story off the coast this is not
something that concerns most Americans
in their spare time all right um he also
in the conversation Dana talked about
how he thinks that we're now far less
tolerant of differing opinions even than
during his administration yeah what do
you think you talked about that before
and in a way that where even on the show
like we've said he's making a good point
he's trying to tell the left guys you
have to allow especially like at college
campuses he's mentioned this before when
his daughters were there in particular
on this issue one of the things he left
out of or at least I didn't I didn't
watch the whole interview with
Christiane Amanpour is that the super
yacht
purchased with money earned through
capitalism
was what helped save the people that
were on the boat that he was concerned
about
so they took the distress call it wasn't
government that went and saved those
people that were in a desperate
situation it was somebody who had a
Caring Heart who said we have the means
we have the upper the obligation as well
because they're out in the Seas they get
a distress call so they went there and
then that was one of the most compelling
things also you can look at the
inequality sure you have people who are
desperate that are leaving Northern
Africa or Syria making that terrible
decision to see like maybe we'll get on
this boat maybe we'll make it there to
the mainland but they know they're
taking a huge risk and they get saved by
the super yacht one of the things that
again this goes back to the conversation
we had just in the previous block which
is somebody like President Obama is in a
wonderful position to help deal with the
problems at their source which is why is
everybody wanting to leave North Africa
why are people still trying to flee
Syria they don't have rule of law they
don't have a hope they don't have a
future they don't have any jobs so what
are they trying to do they're trying to
get to some place that is better our
systems are better we should try I think
to help encourage those countries to do
better for their people by doing what we
do awesome judge final thoughts I I
agree with what Greg was saying about
false comparisons uh when I was the D.A
one of the first cases I had involved a
body uh and it had been chopped up and I
remember calling the New York Times uh
and saying I need your help with this
you know if we could get some coverage
on it I might be able to get some
traction and the question that they
asked me was did I think it was a famous
or rich person
I will never ever forget that and that's
when it made it clear to me that the
things that get coverage the things that
people are interested in are things that
are you know affect people that we're
not used to or that we're not used to
seeing and so we have become immune to
people the boats capsizing to people you
know suffering and dying on the way to
it trying to get to a new life but I
think I think it's really rich that it's
Barack Obama you know the guy who went
from 1.5 million net worth to now I
think it's more than 70 million dollars
net worth
um where you know he's talking about the
fact that um or when he when he created
his um uh the Obama I think Center 90 of
the voters on the south side of Chicago
were very upset about it and the nurse
City officials to do more to create
affordable housing because it was the
Obama Center that was moving those
people out of the south side of Chicago
and I think it's really rich for him to
talk about all the division and the
press and everything else when he was
from Chicago where there was so much
crime and so many inner city kids in his
own City so he ought to maybe look in
his own house a little bit before he
starts criticizing people for being
fascinated by what is truly a
fascinating story